merci dominique alors pour mieux
comprendre ce coup de force il faut
revenir à l'histoire de cette guerre
oubliée sur laquelle l'occident ferme
les yeux
quelques points de repères d'avoir la
tchétchénie est un territoire grand
comme quatre départements français
peuplée d'un million d'habitants environ
mais qui a une importance stratégique
pour l'exportation du pétrole du caucase
entre autres et tchétchènes connaissent
la domination russe depuis des siècles
en 91 avec l'effondrement de l'union
soviétique ils ont cru leur arrivée mais
leur déclaration d'indépendance a été
rejetée par moscou deux guerres sont
suivis gilles rabin décembre 94 parce
que la tchétchénie vient de proclamer
son indépendance
boris eltsine lancé soldats à l'assaut
de la petite république du caucase
première offensive sur la capitale
grozny pendant la nuit de la
saint-sylvestre 95 et l'armée russe subi
la plus grande défaite de son histoire
elle perd près de 300 chars et presque
un millier d'hommes
en une nuit la première guerre de
tchétchénie ne sera qu'une longue série
de batailles inutiles de massacres des
chèques et deux défaites pour la russie
déjà en juin 95 les rebelles tchétchènes
avaient pris en otage 1500 personnes
dans un hôpital du sud de la russie
aboud ionov permis russes avaient donné
l'assaut cent cinquante otages avaient
été tués
deux mois plus tard à cesser feu avait
été signé au printemps 96 alors que
boris elstine doit se faire élire pour
un nouveau mandat il est clair que la
russie n'est plus en mesure de gagner
cette guerre
et c'est un général qui fera la paix
alexandre liébé la deuxième guerre de
tchétchénie commence en fait à moscou à
la fin de l'été 99 deux immeubles
d'habitation explosé s'effondre il ya
plus de 300 morts
vladimir poutine qui est alors le
premier ministre weil alcine et son
dauphin désigné accuse aussitôt les
tchétchènes
nous poursuivrons les terroristes
partout
à l'aéroport s'ils sont à l'aéroport et
excusez-moi si sans toilettes
on y aura débuté dans les chiottes
l'armée russe reçoit carte blanche elle
croyait avoir affaire à une guerre elle
doit en fait affronter une guérilla
mille jours de combats plus tard plus de
20000 morts presque un demi million de
réfugiés la capitale grozny détruite
comme la plupart des villes et des
villages de tchétchénie l'armée russe
est enlisée et pire elle a perdu son âme
et son honneur par la bataille les
exactions se multiplient viols meurtres
raquette ratissage aveugle torture dans
les sinistres camps de filtration les
crimes de guerre se multiplient très
vite à huis clos
le kremlin a en effet interdit la
tchétchénie à tout témoin journalistes
ou personnel humanitaire en septembre
dernier les combattants tchétchènes
abattent un hélicoptère aux portes de la
plus grande base russe 118 morts c'est
le premier défi direct au maître du
kremlin
le deuxième défi c'est la prise d'otage
en cours à moscou voilà moscou